[Música]
y llegamos a ecuador porque ese país
vuelve a ser noticia por una nueva riña
carcelaria en la cárcel de santo domingo
vamos a saludar entonces a nuestro
corresponsal en quitó la capital gustavo
ortega gustavo lo saludo muy buen día
ampliamos entonces esta información en
el mismo escenario desde hace un mes se
vuelve a ser el centro de riñas
carcelarias que pasó en ese lugar
y para ti tal y como tú has dicho el
mismo escenario que durante el mes de
mayo de este mismo año habrían fallecido
asesinado a 44 reos por riñas entre
distintas bandas delictivas y habrían
también contabiliza 210 personas serías
es escenario nuevamente de un nuevo
levantamiento el día de hoy también se
conoce sobre una nueva riña carcelaria
que ocurrió específicamente en el centro
carcelario de bellavista en la provincia
de santo domingo donde ya el ejecutivo
de nacional es informado sobre el
levantamiento de 13 cuerpos
causados por nuevamente riñas
carcelarias esto según el ministro de
interior de justicia había dicho que se
produjeron enfrentamientos entre el
pabellón de mínima y máxima seguridad
específicamente por el control del
centro penitenciario sólo se ha dicho y
que ya se tira del control pero
permanecen los distintos operativos de
seguridad tanto al interno como en el
exterior del centro carcelario para
garantizar así el control de la
seguridad pero habrían sido también los
familiares quienes habrían el comunicado
luego que los propios reos
en ayuda y alerta emitiendo mensajes de
celulares y vídeos que dan cuenta de una
violencia en máxima y las imágenes son
realmente crudas en cuanto a lo que
sucede al interno de este centro
carcelario gustavo le pregunto que ha
informado el ejecutivo nacional en
cuanto a este nuevo levantamiento es de
nuevo el caso de riña carcelaria
pero el príncipe lo único que está
informado que se habría originado por la
creación de una nueva banda delictiva
que el cual buscaba el control del
pabellón de mínima seguridad también se
ha informado sobre el traslado de 32
reos recordemos que el ejecutivo
nacional había emitido una orden de
trasladar a las cárceles de máxima
seguridad a los líderes de las bandas
delictivas cuando se produzcan este tipo
de levantamiento ya se produzca se
produjo un traslado a la cárcel de la
roca se informó inclusive que serían
trasladados otros reos a la cárcel de
máxima seguridad de la roca ubicada en
la ciudad de guayaquil por ahora sólo se
ha indicado que ya se mantiene al
control de este centro carcelario pero
se espera inclusive que el presidente de
la república reciba un informe para
evaluar cómo ha sido este desempeño de
las autoridades de los centros
penitenciarios y se espera que se pueda
producir un informe por parte del
presidente de la republica en lo que ha
sido nuevamente una gresca en un centro
carcelario en este país